hier hat 20.000 menschen wurden erwartet
aber es scheint zumindest von den
bildern die wir hier sehen weitaus mehr
zu sein
ganz genau wir sind jetzt auch gerade
mittendrin in der demo nicht nur einmal
meine maske ab weil er mich dann besser
versteht und es sind tatsächlich
deutlich mehr als 20.000 tatsächlich
wurden gerade hunderttausend leute
durchgegeben dass die sich hier
versammelt haben und eine von denen ist
julia die hier bei mir steht julia warum
seit ich hier was ist euch besonders
wichtig jetzt wichtig einfach im zeichen
zu setzen man kann jetzt zu der zeit
nicht viel machen aber man will einfach
zeigen frieden ist es wichtig so und ich
glaube deswegen sind so viele leute
heute einfach hier zusammengekommen und
ein zeichen zu setzen dass wir sind alle
hinter den ganzen leuten und ja das ist
einfach das wichtigste und
krieg führt einfach zu nichts weshalb
ich finde es auch tatsächlich eine ganz
beeindruckende stimmung hier weil alle
tatsächlich sehr friedlich hier sind
aber tatsächlich doch viele schilder
gebastelt wurden und so weiter wie
nimmst du die stimmung hier so war ja
ich bin super was ist auch gut findet
dass die leute nicht die schuld auf
russland schieben sondern wirklich putin
total im fokus haben also man sieht hier
karikaturen über putin man sieht
wirklich
slogans fakt putin das finde ich halt
auch super dass die leute jetzt nicht
irgendwie komplett jede person
russischer staatsbürger ist in den fokus
setzen sondern es ist halt irgendwie
eine entscheidung die von oben kommt und
die ist einfach scheiße vielen dank
erstmal an dich viel spaß wenn man das
so sagen kann hier noch oder viel erfolg
zumindest wir wollen wir einmal mein
kameramann luka kamali
hochschalten beziehungsweise hoch zeigen
wie voll diese straßen sieht man das
brandenburger tor ist es wirklich ganz
ganz überwältigend wie viele menschen
hier sind wir sind hier gerade durch den
berliner tiergarten durch diesen
riesengroßen parc du kannst du
vielleicht ein bisschen drehen einmal
zur anderen seite auch dass man mal
sieht wie viele menschen hier sind und
auch der ganze berliner tiergarten war
gerade schon voll voll mit menschen die
sich eben darüber auch unterhalten haben
warum die menschen hier jetzt gerade
eben auf der straße sind viele haben
oder ich habe gerade einmal
aufgeschnappt dass ich viele auch über
donald trump irgendwie und halten haben
wir zum beispiel gesagt haben stellt
euch mal vor der wäre jetzt noch an der
macht also wirklich großes
gesprächsthema hier viele menschen die
ja für den für den guten zweck
beziehungsweise eben gegen den krieg
hier auf die straße gehen und gegen
putin danke für diese eindrücke bild
reporterin kira ortmann dort von der
straße des 17 juni zwischen tiergarten
und brandenburger tor ist alles voll mit
menschen mit menschen die heute für die
ukraine gegen putin dort auf die straße
gegangen sind wir haben gerade während
wir mit dirk iran noch gesprochen haben
inoffizielle meldungen bekommen nachdem
der 500.000 heute in den straßen
unterwegs sein sollen das sind
gigantische bilder heute zeichen für die
solidarität mit der ukraine nicht und
das sind bilder die wir hier auch noch
einmal kurz auf uns wirken lassen wollen
500.000 menschen laut veranstaltungen
dort jetzt gerade auf der straße für die
ukraine hier im herzen von berlin
zwischen brandenburger tor und der
siegessäule das passiert also gerade
hier in unserer hauptstadt live ja was
für ein tag diese live bilder hier aus
der hauptstadt